[Music]
straight ahead on long crime daily
over here you see another area where a
body was turned and then
drove to
the same area of the residence also you
see a partial footwear impressions in
blood testimony continues in ohio's pike
county massacre trial as george wagner
iv faces the possibility of the death
penalty plus cardi b and a guilty plea
the rapper makes a deal to avoid jail
time after assault at a new york strip
club and you know what i won't hear it i
don't know what you're insulting me on
the record in front of my client you've
been insulting me the entire trial so
blatantly sparks fly between the judge
and defense attorneys during the penalty
phase trial of the parkland school
shooter and later arguments outside the
presence of the jury get heated in the
alex jones defamation trial the basis
for the upholding that objection is
we're ready for the jury that's not a
legal basis judge
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckman a law
enforcement agent testifies about
gathering evidence from one of the
several crime scenes in the long-awaited
trial of george wagner iv one of several
defendants charged in ohio's 2016 pike
county massacre
wagner along with his brother jake and
their parents are charged with murdering
eight members of the rhoden and gilley
families in april of 2016. the shooting
deaths allegedly came amid an ugly
custody dispute involving a young child
jake shared with hannah rhoden the
victims were found shot to death in
their homes most were shot as they slept
jake previously pled guilty to the
murders and will spend the rest of his
life in prison he has agreed to testify
against his brother and father george
wagner's defense argues he's not guilty
because he didn't actually pull the
trigger jurors toured the several crime
scenes locations before the trial began
ohio bureau of investigation agent shane
hanshaw testified friday about
processing one of the crime scenes chris
wrote in seniors trailer and property
where he and gary rhoden's bodies were
found he said there were bullets and
blood found in different spots across
the crime scene the images shown in
court were not recorded or broadcasted
but hanshaw told jurors there was
evidence of the bodies possibly being
dragged
tell us what stood out to you when you
did that initial look
when i initially
went up to the
on the front porch
and looked inside
um i noticed that there were multiple
bullet holes in the front of the house
near the area of the door
there was a
actually a bullet hole through the
screen door the frame
one of the things i noticed at that
point is there was not a bullet hole in
the front entrance door
and i noticed that there were blood
stains on the door itself on the
exterior portion
and having
seen that that led me to believe that
the front door was most likely open when
the bloodletting event had occurred if
you could tell the jury
what they're looking at there
from that general area
you will see
what would be transfer stains here in
blood
uh and their transfer they're in the
form of maybe a drag
it appeared that individuals
that a bloodletting event had occurred
within the residence and the individuals
were drugged throughout the residence
joining us today is professor of law at
new york law kirk burkhalter and co-host
terry austin professor as week one comes
to an end what are the prosecution's
strongest arguments that you're seeing
in this case
well what's interesting here is under
our system of criminal justice a
defendant is innocent until proven
guilty but the prosecution's strongest
argument will be in the negative meaning
given the horrific nature of the crime
scene the fact that his co-defendants
pled guilty
what other explanation can the defendant
give other than his guilt so i think
we'll see the prosecution lining up
those chips in that fashion and putting
the ball so to speak in the defendant's
court yeah it's a lot of chips to kind
of stack against him because you said
there's a lot of evidence a lot of
testimony against him terry agent
hanshaw provided a lot of detailed
testimony today what stood out to you
well the first thing i thought about was
what the prosecution said during her
opening she basically mentioned the fact
that there were two of these victims who
were shot while they were up and active
and alive and clearly it was chris
rhoden and gary rhoden because there's
no question that they came to that door
and allegedly the wagners opened that
door and began shooting and then
ultimately had to drag the bodies now
granted agent henshaw's his testimony
was long it was detailed it went over
pictures it went over what he found
there but ultimately you do get the big
picture that
he really described what happened on
that scene when no one else could really
describe it if you look at what he said
you understand that these people were
probably fighting for their lives yeah
it really brings the jury to that place
not only moments after discovering their
bodies but also probably a little bit as
to what happened when the shooting
occurred it's probably strong evidence
for the prosecution well switching now
to florida where a fast food worker is
being praised for his quick response to
a customer in need law and crime network
correspondent sierra gillespie explains
how one chick-fil-a employee went above
and beyond with his service
[Music]
a daring rescue from a fast food worker
who rushes to save a woman and her baby
from an attempted carjacking
how dare you scare her like that it
happened on wednesday outside of a
chick-fil-a in fort walton beach florida
officials with the oskaloosa county
sheriff's office say a woman was taking
her baby out of a vehicle when a man
wielding a stick approached demanding
her keys they say the man later
identified as 43 year old william branch
then grabbed the keys from her waistband
opened her car door and jumped inside
when the woman began screaming a
chick-fil-a employee ran to her aid
branch punched the chick-fil-a worker in
the face before several more people
approached to help restrain him
onlookers then scolded branch for his
actions
branch was later arrested and charged
with carjacking with a weapon and
battery the oskaloosa county sheriff
tweeted out a video of the incident
saying quote a major shout out to this
young man for his courage reporting for
long crime network i'm sierra gillespie
still ahead on law and crime daily
fireworks in the courtroom after the
defense press its case early what that
early break could mean for the parkland
school shooter but first cardi b pleads
guilty following a brawl at a new york
city strip club one sentence was handed
down to the hip-hop singer
[Music]
welcome back rapper and songwriter cardi
b has avoided jail time after pleading
guilty to misdemeanor assault charges
the charges stemmed from a bottle
throwing attack at a strip club in
queens back in 2018. le star was one of
10 people involved in the brawl
following a dispute with the club's
bartenders sisters jade and batty g
cardi b are reportedly believed one of
them had an affair with her husband
offset she was charged with misdemeanor
assault and reckless endangerment along
with 10 other charges the rapper was set
to go to trial over the charges this
week but accepted a plea deal to avoid
any jail time the deal included a guilty
plea to third degree assault and second
degree reckless endangerment and the
other charges were dismissed
she's been sentenced to 15 days of
community service and is ordered to stay
away from the woman who was involved
if she fails to complete the community
service by january cardi b could face
jail time
terry does
community service sound appropriate for
what cardi b pled guilty to i mean
people may think it's not appropriate
but i think here it is appropriate i
mean it was assault it was reckless
endangerment but it was really prompted
by a crime of passion this was a bar
brawl for all intents and purposes she
did throw a drink at the bartender she
did throw a bottle apparently but she
owned up to it and i do think that that
helped as far as the prosecution was
concerned for her to admit culpability
here and for her to say that she's
changed it's not going to happen again i
do think there will be people who think
this is not enough but don't forget
there is also a protective order she
can't go around those people again and
frankly i don't think that's going to be
her focus i think her focus is going to
be
focusing on her career her music her
children so that's i think what's going
to happen here so i think it's
appropriate yeah and there might have
been a little ton tied the order
protection she has stayed away from all
of the women and i think it's a
misdemeanor so it'll be five years and
to that point kirk the charges are
misdemeanors meaning she could have done
up to a year in jail so if she's doing
community service why plead guilty to
these crimes and not something less
well
terry hit the nail on the head this is a
bar fight and she probably wanted to get
this off her plate as soon as humanly
possible and if she can get away uh not
get away rather but just um get out of
this without doing jail time and just
doing community service then that's
probably uh the best way for her to move
on i am certain that we will see a few
photo opportunities photos from photo
opportunities of her doing community
service
she's a
public figure performer doesn't need a
trial hanging over her head doesn't need
folks tuning in
and seeing the trial of cardi b for the
next year yeah i don't think a trial is
going to really hurt her chances of
making money going forward but thanks
for the update guys also in celebrity
legal news singer nicki minaj slams a
gossip blogger with a defamation suit
after she called the pop star a coke
head menage is seeking 75 thousand
dollars in damages from marley green the
woman behind the so-called nosy hoes
blog
green posted a video on monday saying in
part quote i'm not saying allegedly on
that nicki minaj is a cokehead her
husband is a rapist green also said
minaj was quote shoving all this cocaine
up her nose she had previously made
comments about the singer's son several
days later minaj filed a defamation suit
in new york supreme court claiming green
made outrage outrageously defamatory
comments minaj noted
a tweet
of green's video received nearly 2 000
likes and more than 200 retweets calling
it a quote firestorm of social media
attention minaj also noted she has never
used cocaine
coming up on law and crime daily the
sandy hook defamation trial out of
connecticut the courtroom gets heated
when a defense attorney argues with the
judge's ruling plus an unexpected break
in the parkland school shooter penalty
phase trial what this pause could mean
for the fate of the defendant
welcome back we're taking a closer look
now the defense's unexpected move to
rest its case abruptly in the parkland
schools shooter penalty phase trial
on wednesday defense attorneys shocked
the prosecution and presiding judge
elizabeth shreer by resting their case
moments before the judge entered the
courtroom the jury entered the courtroom
sorry before this defense attorneys
refused to indicate who the next witness
would be or which attorney would
question the witness in february of 2018
the defendant opened fire at marjory
stoneman douglas high school killing 17
people and injuring 17 others the gunman
later pled guilty to all charges leading
to this penalty phase trial where a jury
will determine whether he receives life
in prison or the death penalty after the
defense rested abruptly on wednesday the
prosecution noted it did not have a
rebuttal case prepared arguing they
expected dozens more witnesses to be
called judge elizabeth called out the
defense for the move saying it was
unprofessional and uncalled for
i just want to say this is the most
uncalled for
unprofessional way to try a case
you you all knew about this and even if
you didn't make your decision until this
morning to have 22 people plus all of
this staff and every attorney march into
court be waiting as if it's some kind of
game
now i have to send them home the state's
not ready they're not gonna have a
witness ready we have another day wasted
i i just i honestly i have never
experienced
a level of unprofessionalism
in my career it's unbelievable
i have been practicing in this county
for two years you know what i don't hear
it i don't know you're insulting me on
the record in front of my client and i
believe that i should be able to okay
you can do that later you can put make
your record later but you've been
insulting me the entire trial so
blatantly taking your headphones off
arguing with me um storming out coming
late intentionally if you don't like my
rulings so quite frankly this has been
long overdue
well both sides will be back in court
for a hearing on monday jurors are not
set to return until september 27th
terry was there a strategy behind what
the defense did can this somehow
backfire on them
brian if there was a strategy it was
definitely not a good strategy and i
think it already has backfired on them
listen they listed dozens of witnesses
and at the last minute they decided not
to call them and listen that's a
legitimate reason if you want not to
have witnesses because it's redundant
that makes sense but to do it and and to
surprise the judge
maybe they wanted to surprise the
prosecution i suppose they have a right
to do that to sort of throw him off his
game but the judge is trying very hard
to run her courtroom and she's trying to
run it and make sure it's efficient and
she raised some excellent points i do
think defense counsel has had it out for
the judge and has intentionally tried to
make things far more difficult so i
think the judge had a right to say all
that she said and during that little
clip i'm curious about their explanation
that whether or not that comes later and
what they do say kirk
how does a rebuttal case work and what
do you expect the prosecution to focus
on
well in a rebuttal there are two things
you want to achieve you want to attack
your adversary's strongest points and
then you want to reinforce your
strongest points
here the defense's strongest points are
the points they tried to make was that
uh nicholas
is not
responsible or not blameworthy enough to
be placed
to death because of his um
mental state and his prolonged history
of the emotional disturbance
um so they would want to rebut that by
stating that that still doesn't mean
that he's not blameworthy and further
reinforce their points
just quite simply the heinous nature of
the crime and keep it short and move on
yeah september 27th we'll see how that
plays out but of course a hearing before
that
and in washington efforts to get
brittany greiner released from a russian
prison continue
as president joe biden meets with the
families of the wnba star and the family
of paul whelan another american being
detained in the country greiner was
arrested in february earlier this year
when she was caught carrying vape
cartridges containing cannabis oil at
the moscow airport grind was charged
with attempting to smuggle illegal
narcotics into russia under russian law
the trial continued despite the guilty
plea in which griner took the stand in
her own defense she testified that she
did not intentionally bring an illegal
substance into the country she was
sentenced to a shocking nine years in
prison in order to pay a 16 thousand
dollar fine the u.s has been in talks to
get greiner back in a possible swap with
russian arms trader victor bao the trade
could also include whelan who has been
in prison for more than three years on
espionage charges the president met with
greiner's wife cheryl and wieland's
sister friday for the first time since
griner and whelan were detained the
white house press secretary says the
meeting aims to assure them of the
administration's commitment to getting
their loved ones
released when we come back the alex
jones definition case out of connecticut
latrell's first week comes to a close
with pushback from the defense team
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily as
week one of the alex jones defamation
trial comes to a close jones defense
attorney and the case's judge butt heads
over an evidence motion
last month jones was ordered to pay more
than 49 million dollars in damages
as part of a separate defamation case
out of texas jones could soon owe even
more in damages as part of another
defamation suit out of connecticut 15
plaintiffs sued jones after he claimed
the sandy hook school shooting was a
hoax put on by actors jones has already
been found liable for damages in this
case meaning jurors will now decide how
much jones should pay on friday defense
attorney norm pattis hoped to show
jurors an interview of jones with anchor
megan kelly when judge barbara bellis
ruled the video could not be played that
is pushed back
the basis of the ruling judge just so i
understand it for the record it can't be
here today because that they don't it's
in
it
i think we're ready for the jury i my
record needs to be complete judge the
basis for
upholding that objection is
we're ready for the jury that's not a
legal basis judge
may i have a ruling that the appellate
court can understand there was an
objection can i sustain you there's no
there was no legal basis stated i'm
entitled to that under the practice book
and you should deny the motion on that
grounds alone it's insufficient for
somebody to stand up they're supposed to
provide me with notice so that i can
respond i believe that he argued for 20
minutes and i think that he's clear to
repackage he said hearsay and if it's if
it's not clear
if it's not clear
it wouldn't be the first time
and you'll move for an articulation and
i'll articulate when i'm directed to by
the appellate court
i understand that there will be an
appeal
i assume well maybe
we might win
maybe not we may win professor the megan
kelly interview was shown in jones's
defamation case in texas so why was it
not played here
well here the prosecution had objection
and i can kind of i'm sorry prosecution
i mean the plaintiff's attorney's had an
objection i can somewhat understand in
that in the video it's a possibility
that jones appears a little sympathetic
it's a little bit of a gotcha video
and further
that there's plenty of blame to go
around right so uh at the end um you
know someone comes on and discusses how
the internet is to blame and other
things so
in this trial it may not necessarily
move the ball uh forward i think that
the plaintiff's attorney is doing a
rather nice job and why kind of move
backwards by showing this video yeah now
terry what did you think of the judge's
ruling and was it appropriate for patis
to say her ruling has no legal basis
well you know there's an old adage as
you know two wrongs don't make her right
and i do think even if judge bellis made
the wrong decision and i don't really
think she did actually i think she had a
right to say look the jury's coming in
we've had the arguments on the record i
can tell you later i've already
sustained that objection and uh you know
basically i think she wanted to get the
court moving but it does behoove norm
pattis the defense counsel to be
respectful the evidence in question is
all about this interview whether it
helps his case or hurts his case she's
already decided it's not coming in she
doesn't think it's relative not more
probative than it is
uh you know prejudicial and so she says
it's not coming in and so i think she
had a right to tell him to sit down
granted kirk i get your point absolutely
that she probably could have said why
but uh that's her discretion
we'll see how this continues on i'm sure
there'll be more sparks flying back and
forth thank you both for joining us and
thank you for joining us here on law and
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you